what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich right so she's
trying to get a lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
pelina marinova pompiano who by the way
has her
guns out sun's not out but the guns are
out what's up
welcome timeout blockfy is now a sponsor
of lunch money she didn't realize that i
was going to do that
uh blackfly's got three products you can
buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar loan or
you can use my favorite product i'm an
investor i sit on the board and i'm a
user
you can get an interest bearing account
that pays up to eight point six percent
apy
no brainer go get money get paid and use
block fi
wifi.com what's up ready
yes i did work out my arms yesterday but
you know
okay house democrat house democrats
prepare
new 2.4 trillion stimulus plan
with unemployment aid and direct
payments you wrote about this this
morning do you want to tell us
what you wrote they have to do it
they're pot committed
they printed three trillion dollars
already they're gonna end up doing over
five this year i called it back in march
march 18th i went back and looked at the
tweet
march 18th how do you know over five how
don't play with my thing because i kept
saying that sounded real sexual i'm just
playing with this
um uh the march 18th
is when things were starting to get
crazy it was two days before the new
york shelter in place
yeah they started to just do things like
the emergency rate cuts there's
quantitative easing and all this stuff
it's just very obviously we're gonna
need a lot of money here uh if they were
gonna do it so either that one was like
let the free market rain and just let it
play out and
yeah people suffer from the short term
would be better long term or you can try
to
mitigate the pain in the short term and
you can screw yourself in the long term
they chose the latter
uh which is dumb but hey that's what
they chose uh it's another pot committed
now they've got to keep printing
uh because we are literally addicted to
the stimulus that's why you see
if you notice right when all the uh
stimulus plans started to run out
all of a sudden the stock market started
to fall do you
think that this will last like
generations
yeah they're they're screwing this all
up by the way i opted out plan b
you all know where to find me
in the bitcoin world it could be a
little rhyme it's fine
all i'm saying is hey i already opted
out y'all can keep playing this stupid
game i'm not playing that game
literally think of think about this you
got politicians who are debating how
many trillions of dollars to print
one wants to print one trillion wants to
print three trillion get out of here
stupid it's all right out of here what's
next all right
ready yes are you ready
oh no no no no no plane is not ready you
see what happened here hold on i'll wait
i'll wait i'm ready i'll wait
i'll damn it i'll tick tock
it's a mess basically um
bite dance says that it will own eighty
percent of tick tock global and the
company will be a subsidiary
oracle contest that by dance will have
no ownership of tick tock global
trump says uh trump says that by dance
will have nothing to do with it and if
they do we won't make the deal
nobody knows what's going on is it 80 is
it no
ownership i don't understand how people
keep talking about the quote-unquote
deal
sounds like there is no deal well how do
you have two sides one says 80 percent
or she goes to zero
sounds like the republicans and
democrats negotiating against thought
that they agreed that
oracle and walmart would be minority
owners
and that bike dance would own the
majority so this makes perfect sense to
me it's what they agreed on
the only thing i'm gonna say is what
i've been saying the whole time
if you threaten to kick them out and
they don't do what you say
kick them out they do it to you
why not do it back all right well that's
the game we're playing now
facebook's not in china google's not in
china all those companies aren't in
china
cool start kicking their things out so
tick tock was set to be banned from
being distributed in the app store on
september 20th which was
last weekend but as the deal got closer
the ban was delayed by a week
and is set to come into effect end of
day of september 27th
will it happen it will happen this is
stupid
this is so dumb just kick them out oh my
god you are zero fun
no i like tick tock that's fine but what
they're doing is they're praying on
america they're literally
stealing all of the data it's so
egregious
so either say to them hey give us the
thing we'll buy it
right and we're going to change things
and and
treat citizens with the privacy and the
data protections that we
believe are important or
see ya what do you want to be yeah
it's just dumb this whole thing is okay
we threatened to kick them out if they
didn't do something and now they're
saying they're not going to do it
so kick them out okay moving on
charles sorry wow carrie schwab
pomerantz is the president of the
charles schwab foundation and senior
vice president of community services and
consumer education at charles
schwab she wrote an op-ed that
covet is showing why we need to make
financial literacy a national priority
increasingly americans are starting to
agree i wrote an entire article on this
how literally nobody is teaching
financial literacy in our schools
in fact two-thirds of americans believe
that financial education should be a
high school graduation
requirement when the survey respondents
reflected on their own lives
the majority wish that they had been
better about saving goal-setting and
investing i love this idea i do
too i think that it's a no-brainer they
should require it they
look think all the things they talk on
trigonometry how many of you guys are
using trigonometry
i wasn't in that class because i was too
dumb i do to calculate your
big head measurements because i got a
treat growing out inside my head
but they taught me trigonometry they
made me go to a film class
i think
like literally when i told you guys i
stopped paying attention in school when
they were like x
and i was like what do you mean there's
letters in math oh well
when there were sentences in math with
the proofs i don't think i don't think
you took
no i don't think i took that class um
but i'm just saying why couldn't they
just teach you like hey here's how you
balance a checkbook
here's how you uh make sure that you
that you spend less than you make hey
here's how you develop multiple streams
of income
hey here's why you should invest right
all this kind of in college i took
personal finance but that was like an
elective it wasn't a requirement
nobody was teaching me that you know how
i got my personal financial education
i was in the street making money
okay um making cash so okay we don't
need to hear about this right now
but um 89 of survey respondents believe
that a lack of financial education
contributes to bigger social issues in
america including poverty lack of job
opportunities and wealth and equality
all the things that we are seeing
today of course get people educated
education is the great equal at the same
time do you think that
being educated in high school like when
you're not really paying attention
for something that you're gonna have to
use as an adult is really
a good idea i think that we should
literally keep everything the same do
whatever you want in schools
i don't care most people know that
school is a waste of time for most
people
okay i wouldn't say that go on go on
college college what you could get a
better education on the internet than
sitting in my house a lot of people
aren't motivated enough and they're
missing the social element
again don't disagree with that
understand a better education the one
specific aspect of an education
but i do think that we should uh
advocate for and teach people much more
practical things
like money money money money
come on okay um it's friday and she
loses her mind
spotify oh stupid ad spotify ceo daniel
eck pledges 1 billion of his wealth to
back
deep tech startups from europe
well he lives in europe i think he is
he's in sweden
um yeah he's gonna he's gonna invest 1.2
billion dollars of his personal fortune
and deep deck
moonshot projects spread across the next
10 years
why is he doing that you may ask he says
i want to do my part we all know that
one of the greatest challenges is access
to capital
uh at he said adding that he wanted to
achieve a new european dream there's
very few companies out of europe that
make it big
and i think that somebody like that who
you know becomes
a pretty big uh operation there's people
there's going to be people who leave who
start their own like it's good
that spotify is based in europe but we
need more
i agree i like big thinkers i think i
feel like daniel eck is exactly that
yup okay cool all right what's next
spotify again
spotify and churn and entertainment
enter our first look deal to turn
podcasts into tv shows and movies what
is a first look deal
so there's all these podcasts that are
blowing up and now what they're going to
start doing is they're going to start
saying hey
we should uh go ahead and
create these into tv shows movies
whatever
and so chernin has basically done a
partnership really with spotify and said
hey we want the first look at this
and i think they committed i think they
committed money uh
and spotify committed money to like be
partners on helping to do that so
spotify basically this is a way for
spotify to
back into um getting in the tv and movie
business
but they don't have to be the experts
they can just party with peter chernin
and his
feeling is like very good peter chernin
is an absolute savage
like i think people i think a lot of
people first heard about him when they
did barstool deal like younger people
uh i mean he is so legit
so legit so you're saying that but why
is it important for
podcasts to be turned into films
basically they have ip
and part of it is like yeah you can
monetize the podcast but what if you
take the exact same
uh idea and you turn it into a netflix
series then you turn it into
tv shows serial the podcast would have
been fascinating as a
show yeah and so they create a
documentary they do this they do yeah
no i don't know i'm just saying i'm
saying that's how they would create
more value for the ip that they have all
right
man cave and very very
they got in trouble at least three mta
employees secretly turned a storage room
below one of the platforms at grand
central terminal in new york into a
private man cave
complete with a futon tv exercise
equipment a fridge and beds
somebody said the mta inspector general
said
many a new yorker has fantasized about
kicking back with a cold beer and
in a prime piece of manhattan real
estate especially one this close to good
transportation
but few would have the hutzpah is that
hey
to commit to commandeer a secret room
beneath grand central terminal
and make it their very own man cave
sustained with mta resources
and maintained at our writer's expense
is this why they raised my mta fair
i like these guys he said wait wait hang
out and get drunk
yeah they use the room to hang out and
get drunk and party
look at this room okay and it's pretty
dope like they got a hole
they got a little futon they got a tv
mounted to the wall
they literally have wi-fi in there they
got a
secret compartment that has a fridge
that had beer
they have a bed in there they've got a
refrigerator and a microwave
oh man these guys were chilling a blow
up mattress
these guys are some savages below track
114.
yeah i mean this is listen is a wire man
a carpenter foreman and an electrical
form and have been suspended without pay
pending resolution of the disciplinary
i kind of respect it although i don't
like that you're using my but i kind of
respect it
what do you mean they built it no look
with the it's a storage closet it wasn't
being used
hey if these three guys want to start a
company i'm it sounds like they're
innovative wow right yeah
all right what's your joke let's go
let's get let's get this out oh she's
not prepared
no no um never forget i never let you
guys down
this day in history so today is
september um 25th
this day in history oh i don't like this
all right we're we're no we're waiting
we're waiting come on come on
let's go your internet is slow
just waiting just waiting by the way
calling it my internet
insinuates that you don't live here and
you weren't the person who bought the
internet
through by calling them because we know
that i can't uh put up with those people
i'm waiting so basically oh in 1789 the
u.s congress proposed a bill of rights
that's kind of cool right
yeah we don't have anything to think but
like the bill of rights
very cool but do you know what i heard
today so he was doing some panel or
conference or something virtual
and the guy on the other end was like
well pumped you know
we have a joke for you to end every
segment and he was like
oh what is it and the guy goes
how does nasa plan events
and he was like i don't know how and
they say they
plan it and i was like he doesn't know
that the
joke's been on lunch money before so he
does all right guys
that's it for lunch money today oh he
didn't try no funny okay
bang bang while while she's trying to
get rich russell's just trying to get
our lunch money right hopefully pelina
will let me get domino's tomorrow i'll
see you guys tomorrow
or monday bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends